hello hello hi this is a science handout
from science mission I am Sadashiva hi
today we have dr. Hameed mid-sized with
us he is the assistant professor in the
Department of Biochemistry Centre for
alzhiemer's and new degenerative
diseases yet UT Texas Southwestern
Medical Center at Dallas so does mr. has
won several awards to his credit as a
grad student he won outstanding the
chemistry - student of all and a grad
student teaching away from Ball State
University he also won dean citation for
academic excellence he was the top 10
most cited author of the Year by ACS few
years ago even missing links award from
cancer prevention Research Institute of
Texas welcome doctor made Mirza thank
you for having me so nice having you
here on our science hangout can you
please tell me about yourself you were
dragged around education etc I finished
my undergraduate studies in Iran and I
moved to United States in 1999 varieties
degree in synthetic organic chemistry
from State University in 2001 I moved to
Purdue University to pursue my PhD in a
field of bio analytical chemistry more
specifically proteomics proteomics is an
area that using mass spectrometry
technique to study protein structure
quantity interactions and expression
after finishing a brief postdoc at
Purdue with my PhD
vizor I moved to Institute for systems
biology to combine my bioanalytical
knowledge with omics and bioinformatics
to be able to do systems biology and I
learn how to use system biology to solve
more complex biological problems I in
principle of system biology is that
instead of using literature or an
observation to generate data they
generate the hypotheses you use omics to
generate large datasets as a screen and
then use those datasets to generate
hypotheses and as a result of the nature
of a hypothesis generation is not biased
after that in 2011 I joined the
Department of Biochemistry the universe
UT Southwestern in Dallas Texas and I
have been involved with drug discovery
and systems pharmacology by using
biochemical tools as well as mass
spectrometry the can you tell me about
your lab the I student post our success
lab briefly sure right now I have one
graduate students and I work with the
senior scientist or permanent positions
I have two instructors their research
track faculty I have a senior research
scientist in my lab I have a senior
research associate and a technician and
you know I have trained three postdocs
they're all having jobs in making a
living but currently I don't have any
post on just one graduate student we
away from research
so other than research what are your
hobbies like anything you are interested
other than places
you know actually this is a very good
question to be honest with you we are
living in a time that we have to spend a
significant amount of time understanding
the political issues because as a
citizen and to make a correct decision I
have to be informed and whatever extra
time I have I spend reading agenda
political agenda different parties try
to understand what is it that each party
is trying to pursue and I also do the
same thing for the local issues in my
city to be able to cast my ballot more
informed so essentially I'm trying to be
an informed citizen and believe it or
not that takes any extra time we have
and like coming back to the science part
of it like like I saw you a recent paper
on hydrazine and how did you come across
the compound and how that led to all
this aging new neural degeneration
finding so can you please elaborate and
you can go ahead and present your work
it is convenient when dimaggio yeah I
think it's all will be part of my
presentation so I think we're going to
go ahead and start the presentation out
there okay can you see a lie present
ok great I first wanted to say that it
took us a little while to build a mass
spectrometry facility and amount of
instruments but in the right corner of
my screen is the faces of very talented
and kind and collaborative team of
people
I have been very fortunate to be able to
work with them I learned from them as
much as they learn from me I just want
to emphasize that whatever via Qi the
achieve was a team and I was blessed
with a very good team very kind
forgiving an elaborate of team so with
that I would like to start my
presentation today I'm going to tell you
talk to you about hydralazine which is
an fda-approved antihypertensive drug
and which we recently discovered that
might have anti-aging properties so in
this presentation I am going to tell you
that hydralazine has other function than
carbon insulation which is a known
function of hydralazine I'm going to
show you that hydralazine activates in
our of two pathway which is a very
pathway or oxidative stress response I'm
going to present data to prove to you
that hydralazine in the activates and
rf2 pathway in various alliance I'm
going to show you that we have validated
our finding themselves in C elegans
which are family of round worms I'm
going to present some data and showing
how hydralazine extends lifespan in
elegant and keep him healthy and also at
the end present some data that had been
acquired to show that hydralazine may
actually have a potential to help great
acidity so you asked the question how
did you care about hydrology so it is
well known that neurodegenerative
diseases and aging are associated with
increased oxidative stress
and that's because many of the defense
machinery such as anti-oxidant defense
machineries and protein folding and
other defense pathways aging experiences
loss of activity so with elevation of
oxidative stress you expect proteins to
become oxidized though in Alzheimer
disease protein called tau and tau in
its natural form it has a function
associated protein but or some reason
that nobody it still knows it assumes a
new conformation which allows it to
aggregate and form rivals and larger
aggregates which are toxic neurotoxic
and they kill neurons nobody knows what
causes a molecule of tau that is
essentially nothing to go through
sitting and how and our plan was to use
carbon
hydralazine as a probe because
hydralazine is fda-approved so we knew
that we injected mice is not going to
kill them it's not going to have you
slide effects not gonna cause oxidative
stress and we knew that it crosses the
blood-brain barrier which was very
important to us because we want to get
and hoping that get mice hydrology pull
down the proteins that are reacting with
hydrology we will find interesting
protein so this is the structure of
hydrology and it has a is known to react
with carbonyls so essentially we wanted
to know if we pulled out carbon elated
proteins if you find interesting
things such as cow or alpha-synuclein or
other proteins and it is known that
hydralazine reacts with acronym which is
a toxin produced after spinal cord
injury and hard allison can mediate a
spinal cord injury by neutralizing
acronym so we knew that it reacts with
carbonyls in vivo and it had a structure
that was not too complex for chemical
synthesis and we also knew that it
crosses the blood-brain barrier so
that's for us was the key oh the
experiment that we treated cells
hydralazine and and with hydrogen
peroxide known cause and then hydrogen
peroxide and heigl as we expected the
amount of carbon elated protein
significantly goes down then we have
hydralazine with the presence of
hydrogen phatso we use a different
smaller molecule called hydrazine as a
positive control and we observe the same
thing as expected because hydrogen or
vanilla
so that experiment led to a very
important observation observation was
made by I the data was presented at a
group meeting three levels as a team
that hydralazine cells that are treated
with hydralazine are not dying than
there are taken hydrogen peroxide the
hydralazine protects cells from hydrogen
peroxide induced by the taxes so we
obviously thought well it's because it
it's organelles and protect the cells
but when we looked at hydrazine which
has the same ability to neutralize
carbonyls we realized that it doesn't
protect the cells so we then realized
that there is something else that's
happened so as I mentioned earlier one
of the my background is in omics and
proteomics is one of the technologies
that are very well-versed at so we
designed an experiment where we grow
cells in media that contains heavy
isotope amino acids and that are
chemically the same but distinguishable
by mass spectrometry alone we
essentially treat one petal cells with
full water and another one with
hydralazine ratio and we measure the
proteins and we look at the proteins
that change ratio and then we use a
software engineering pathway analysis or
IPA who project our data and identify
molecular pathways are activated so when
we did that we realized that one of the
pathways that's activating the collagen
treatment is nrf2
now nrf2 is a very important
transcription factor that's upstream of
up to 200 anti oxidative stress
functions including tyree toxin and
glutathione in 201 and many other
antioxidant enzymes so we obviously the
stress that we put our cells on there
was oxidative stress and it was very
interesting to us that the transcription
factor
that is responsible for responding to
that kind of stress yes activate of
course in the presence of hydralazine if
you don't have hydralazine you don't you
don't get activation so in order to
pathway is fairly complicated it's in
normal condition nrf2 that forms a
complex with a protein called Chi Quan
and called Li and it gets ubiquitinated
by coffee and it has a half-life of 30
minutes and but if there is oxidative
stress then nrf2 is released from one
and then it trans it transported into
the nucleon where it's from the complex
laughs and finds the a re or antioxidant
element and then expresses all the
downstream targets so we set out to
determine if our compound indeed
activates an RFT
the first experiment we look at the
expression of an RF 2 and as you can see
here with Western blot and IP and as
well as mass spectrometry that treatment
of cells with hydrogen with hydralazine
the absence of any stress increases the
the concentration of an RF to fold
almost we also did any reciprocal IP in
one experiment we pull down an RF - and
measured G :
and with the other experiment we pull
down keep one and measured in RF - in
the presence of hydralazine and if
hydralazine functions by activating in
RF - which decrease
yeah interaction wonder that that's
exactly what we saw both by people the
extra step was that well if nrf2 is
released from its complex it has to be
transported into the movie if it's not
in the nucleus and not it's not
functional so we looked at the cytosolic
level of nrf2 and nucleus level of nrf2
and we determined that level of nrf2
does not change cytosol with hydralazine
children but it goes up in the nucleus
of the cell when is treated with
hydrolysis indicating that not only
honor of two is released from his
complex but it also can towards the
nucleus of the cell the next step is
that nrf2 according to literature it
phosphorylated and before it and form a
complex math and blind
avery so we measured also the
phosphorylation of nrf2 both in the
cytosol and nucleus and we showed that
the nuclear energy phosphorylation
significantly increases the tiger
allison treatment but the cytosolic a
phosphorylation does not change as the
next test that we did was to determine
if nrf2 indeed binds to a re and because
if it doesn't bind a re it will not be
considered functional so there's an
assay where a re is drives this varies
expression and it sells we showed that
when we add an of two and privacy face
expression in a dose-dependent manner
would go up so it was an additional
confirmation that binding in order to to
a orys function we went even further and
we assumed that if an RFQ binds to the
Mari the downstream targets of an earth
who should go up the expression so we
measured the amount of downstream
targets of Faerie both by quantitative
if you are destined block and he showed
that all know downstream targets of an
article or in hydrology treatment as one
would expect that activation of an RFT
pathway so although these data are quite
convincing that nrf2 is activated we
propose recipe but they were all in heat
related cells their culture and not in a
living organ so further our study we
used the elegance around them and C
elegans was my model for us because it
has a block of N or of the one and one
in C elegans it is expressed in
intestine VI and in the animal
so as a third step
we won
there are gfp-tagged
that means that if their level of you
could measure esteem on up regulation
measuring GDP signal and as you can see
in this slide in the reigning of C
elegans treated with hydralazine
obviously there is more expression of
scheme 1 and on the right side of the
slide there is a population analysis
showing that that asi more on skin 1
expression goes up compatible with cells
the next we measured the expression of a
skin one in the intestinal loop because
that's also there this pacific
transcription factor is expressed and
again we observe the same thing nuclei
with significant number of gfp-tagged
discs in one go up and we have operation
skip one in the STI as well so we wanted
to make sure that our findings or
correct so we used a downstream target
of the skin one of GST for promoter that
expresses gfp so the idea is if AG
allison activates testing one intestinal
apply it should also increase the
expression of ESP that is driven by GST
for more and that's exactly what we see
in the left side slide
work right up on the right side on the
other hand you can see that when he won
our nai is used to knock down 51 had
been no longer see expression of GFP by
dollars and treatment indicating that
not only skin one is activated but also
their downstream target sector we also
performed pathway analysis we have done
it previously in SH Y cells before
neuroblastoma cells but we hadn't done
in in worms
so we repeated the experiments but
instead of using silac technology and
the same analysis and we found that in
order to pathway or the foresting one
pathway rather is activated in warms in
2007 Bishop and grant a show that the SK
one that is expressed in a assignment
has mediates the extension of lifespan
that is the result of dietary
restriction so it is a well in fact that
dietary calorie restriction increases
the live stream of animals and recent
study done at NIH Michigan put this
controversy west by showing that even in
higher primates like chimpanzees by
restriction increased so but nobody
knows how in this important work by
Bishop and Gregory they show that
actually
it is team one that some endocrine
signaling increases the metabolism and
leads to increased longevity so we
thought that if hydralazine indeed
activates skin one which what was
observed with our GP studies warms are
treated the collagen should experience
extension of lifespan and that's exactly
what we observe that when we treat of
warms their median lifespan increases as
25% which would be equivalent of if
human being living on years instead of
35 years so that's very good and it
shows that hydrolysis in activates skin
one in the chemist sensory neurons and
extends the lifespan there are other
compounds that are known to increase
lifespan and such as the forming and
welcoming but again an important point
in using something like hydrology is
that nobody is going to start taking
herbalism from childhood and what works
it should work at later stages so in
this study we look at late stage
administration of mechanism and we
actually observed that my dollars and
protects the worms of a 17% at the late
stage administration which is comparable
with metformin and totally better than
important as a next step we knock down
on asking one and we show that then skin
one is not found and hydralazine no
longer and increased life and
of C elegans a major concern that
lifespan is the quality of life
essentially it means that there is no
point in living longer they are not
healthy so in addition to measuring the
lifespan we measured their locomotive
performance locomotive performance of
warms is an presentative of their health
essentially we measured the number of
time double per minute and then use that
as a measure of health and as you can
see in this figure worms that are
treated with hydrology are showing much
lower increase in the locomotive
performance compared to ones in which
both the most isoforms of its p1 or have
loss of function mutations so it's true
dollars makes the woman live longer but
makes them live healthier too so we
wanted to there are other mechanisms
that could have similar effects that for
example if hydralazine interferes with
the ability of one's it essentially
creates dietary restriction and so we
measured the average pumps per minute
and showed that worms that are treated
with hydralazine are essentially no
different than normal ones in the
ability to swallow whoo
we also looked at other important player
is known to extend lifespan such as hip
bone and HSL form and we showed that
none of them change and it seems that
it's specific to realism we also looked
at daf-16
which is also another protein known to
increase the lifespan when it said I
believe downregulated
and we showed that that's also not
involved because when it's a mutated and
unfunctional we see that still lifespan
we also looked at bacteria which is a
source of the food for cl- there's a
recent study that showed that metformin
actually extend the lifespan by changing
the metabolism of the bacteria and and
and that's reason behind and one of the
reasons in study we showed that
hypothesis does not interfere with the
metabolism of bacteria which would
affect the reforms as the source but how
about nrf2 in or degenerative diseases
that oxidative stress was a inflammation
infection they're all causing activation
of Astral microbial which are
essentially cells surround the normals
and David with reactive oxygen species
that in turn can damage neurons but
unfortunately it is scientists have
discovered that many of the diseases
such as Alzheimer disease Parkinson
division ALS not only
and rf2 is not up regulated manage D all
this is actually lower for various
reasons if the level of nrf2 or
downstream targets are significantly
decreased which means that not only
cells are under more oxidative stress
their defense mechanisms or become less
functional so we had two questions we
wanted to know if all he initially had
cells at 4-under hydrogen oxide toxicity
experienced protection with federalism
treatment hydrogen peroxide is a very
nice model for disease and this was in
regional and the other question that we
had was that even though high dollars
are activated afternoon but it's not
tenfold but rather milder increased
activity and we wanted to know if that
level of increase in activity not affect
animals and cells so in one experiment
we used primary neuronal cells these are
cells or extracted from the hippocampus
of the mouse top at a zero and their
culture and after 20 days we treated
them rotenone rotenone is a complex
mitochondrial complex one inhibitor and
mice did with rotenone develop Parkinson
so when these primary neuronal cells
brought you know a significant decrease
or viability but when we add hydralazine
they almost win him back
their normal level quite good in terms
of providing protection the next focused
on the silicon and forms wrote alone
again and we show that hydralazine and
also protect the elegance from rotenone
and ecstasy
we also measured the promoter
performance again there is no point in
living long and we are showing here that
not only morons treated with rotenone
and hydrology in longer and forms and
that only our children but also become
better local performance evidence that
ideology protects both the mechanisms
that regulate aging and also mechanism
so the next used autocracy model of
elegance these worms have they're two
different string one string there's a
towel fresh and that's not like we get
the other as chain has how the does
agony and here which in hydrology
context increase the lifespan both
regardless of the state of cow
aggregation which means that if there
are very general mechanisms that protect
cells and it we observed the same so
this is an essentially a model a
more model I should act for for
Alzheimer disease and we are singing
benevolence are experiencing protection
if agonism shitty and finally we wanted
to compare the protective properties of
an rs2 so we compared it a I be compared
hydralazine the hydrazine which has the
same function which sodium chlorite
because ideology is a salt with opening
and the third thing which as the first
thing is known in RF practically it
essentially instructs the interaction
and as you can see adult food provides
the best protection of all the other
components oh um I hope that I made a
call on my person hydralazine protect
cells from hydrogen hydralazine does
that by activating which is a property
in addition to organization I would like
to emphasize that the carbonyl chelation
ability and $5 is also very helpful in
controlling the damage caused by the
active species technology then life span
across time in C elegans and in a in one
dependent manner which is the ortholog
of an RFT and ideology mediated in order
to ask in one activation provides no
protection at the end i want to add that
i dollars in is SP approved and being
used for layers all the side effects are
known
and it crosses the blood-brain barrier
which is very important when you are
trying to find out drug have a tree that
would treat neurodegenerative diseases
at the end I would like to thank all my
team always won by a smile research
associate and heart when he was a
graduate student gradually in vitro work
where measured were done by each one
lung cancer feature although some also
come with a smile and Marian and the
bioinformatics were done by Mohammed do
that we had a lot of support if he saw
Weston is a highly collaborative
environment I my wonderful chair dr.
Steven McKnight provided a lot of
support dr. Larkin I'm going to be
director of the Center for Alzheimer
disease
dr. Campbell who's Amy and a star or any
chemistry some minik synthesis and last
play not lead but the ruling name and
spell Robertson the profits of our paper
helped us thank you very much in this
very good thank you very much really
very nice sure
the elegance is that in the
accommodation of cow or anything I can
barely hear you
okay so what was the question again
in the system yes yes exactly
yes I there is a lot of data that I have
not shown obviously it's not possible to
show everything we have other manuscript
operation that focus on other aspect of
this drug and yes we have evidence that
hydralazine actually clears these toxic
aggregates but through other mechanisms
which I will not elaborate now our
future al-ahmad like that we played in a
mouse model or anything like that for
genetic diseases sorry but mouse model
you know any mouse model for output like
a degeneration yes
you know these mice you can you have to
buy them at 2 months of age and then we
have to house them for 6 months before
they get old enough and develop the
Alzheimer phenotype and we are in the
process of essentially raising these
mice to get to the age that they should
and then do the necessary process the
data yeah I don't have anything else
like it's interesting that only one of
the proteins were odd I'm not sure you
might have data for the proteins
like noodle productivity
what was your if there any other protein
is the only another no no there are
other pathways that are activated as I
mentioned but we will hopefully
publishing near future and all aspects
of and made thank you very much I really
appreciate so if you want to has been
published in multiple you can again come
back absolutely what pleasure and I hope
that work creates some enthusiasm in
young people to join and are suited
career in science you don't mind me
giving your email address right because
I'm Facebook and all those things thank
you so much again absolutely